[Musik]
beste frau wanderte er aus
idealistischen gründen nach burkina faso
aus das westafrikanische land zählt zu
den ärmsten der welt noch immer brennt
ihn ihr das vor der 68er bewegung
biologische ihres engagement als ganzes
natürlich solidarität und manchmal habt
genug für sie
dann ist man verpflichtet zum gehen hier
lebt ist frei den alltag in ihrer
wahlheimat welchen gefahren setzt sich
die schweizerin aus und worin findet sie
ihre erfüllung davon gibt diese
reportage diese geschichte beginnt 2015
in zürich
der zürcher kreis 4 war für die
studierte psychologin jahrzehntelang ihr
zuhause
ja das ist krieg als verluste genau
hysterisch abgerissen und da wird zum
glück klappt hielt und ruß was mir als
er in gewohnt aber sonst fühle mich ganz
häufig stoltz kopf erwischt
beruflich war sich vor allem im
personalbereich tätig nach ihr
pensionierungen will sie nun zu neuen
ufern aufbrechen
20 verlage darunter
irgendwann ist mir einfach satt und ich
habe aus dem vollen schöpfen und hatte
sehr kurze und jetzt finden die nicht
einfach so weitermachen in der
mannschaft wählen dann weil ihnen aus
konsum trocken und das wetter net sie
hinter österreich liegen bewegte und
engagierte jahre als kind der 68er
bewegung war sie stets politisch aktiv
sie war mitgründerin der gruppe für eine
schweiz ohne armee stelle ihren idealen
ist sie zeitlebens treu geblieben
ich wähle irgendwas mit waffe oder metro
metro hat auch stellt sie hätte keine
großbank will ich hoffe ich kann sehr
acht war sich auch innerhalb von der
gesellschaft bewirken diese wohnung ist
schon über 35 jahre lang er zu hause
eine zeit lang lebte die kinderlose frau
hier mit ihrem partner zusammen
die ehe mit dem nigerianer gegen in die
brüche aber ihre liebe zu afrika ist
geblieben
haben sie dann aber doch wie chronische
seele
ich kann absolut die hainich entwickelt
riskio afrikanische tanz und do 20 jahre
zusammenarbeit mit afrika wo nicht
klappt show rette die afrikanischen teil
vom innere sehe auch eine stärkere
dollar ist ein revolutionsführer aus
burkina faso
dorthin will sie auch andere die wohnung
hat sie bereits gekündigt
das kriegen
das hat mich sehr glücklich gemacht für
mich um die zisch abschied verdient
[Musik]
drei jahre später 2018 in der stadt
koudougou in burkina faso hat sich
esther frei inzwischen ein stattliches
haus bauen lassen ihre hase steht
inmitten eines von armut geprägten
quartiers und kostete rund
hunderttausend franken
das anwesen wirkt wie ein magnet für die
menschen der umgebung
das ist er sich in der theorie der
näherin von quartier ist groß sie
einfach für die nachbarschaft dass sie
show und ein handtor viel noch möglich
die misere sind wo von tag zu tag nicht
weiß was leistet das spielzeug gehört
nicht in den mund
er schließt die tür
rund 300 franken gibt sie monatlich für
sich aus das ermöglicht der 67-jährigen
für hiesige verhältnisse ein leben in
luxus fließen wenn ich da haben mit
seinem logo das ist ein absoluter luxus
das land wirklich nur mittelschicht ein
quartier für das nominierende sie sich
vor dass sie dass sie das lied all
ziehend mit tieren aber stand autos sich
und leichter da tue nämlich die absicht
also ich koche ich sagte die vorne weg
nötig sind weil das warme wetter sind
jetzt grad am morgen hatte ich endlich
seit anfang sie wählen da wo ich jetzt
bin ich auf fange ich habe mit all ihren
firmenstandort wenn aber das ist ein
lernprozess das ist schwierig zu wissen
wer hat was wirklich nötig und weil ich
nur einfach zu zum 6 diese arbeiter ihre
direkten nachbarn zum beispiel sie
könnten mehr aus ihrem leben machen dies
test affäre überzeugt immer wieder
bringt sie ihnen etwas zu essen
jetzt kommst du damit etwas feines
diesmal gibt sie dem ehepaar mehr als
nur gemüse sie hält den beiden auch
einem raub predigt warum pflanzt du hier
keinen baum
dieser hof gehört einem onkel und du
wartest doch auf dass er kommt um einen
baum zu pflanzen
das kannst du doch selber machen der
alkohol macht sich passiv man ist ein
bisschen hier man trinkt anstatt zu
arbeiten
du musst hier einen baum pflanzen ich
habe nicht die kraft
es ist nur der alkohol der macht alles
kaputt
[Musik]
vor der haustür trifft sie auf einen
weinenden bub hat er sich geschlagen
du warst böse mit ihm warum hast du ihn
geschlagen gehweg vom sand der alltag
ist hart und einfach nachbarschaftshilfe
ist lebenswichtig konkrete verteilung
auf boni habe ich die hilfe bevor waren
diesmal malaria kann
sie erzählt dass ich euch hier an und
hat sich seit so richtig niederweiler
ich schlafe mit ihr und sie hat mich
überwacht während der krankheit und ganz
viele andere sind gut mit mir früchte
bringen
man muss sich mal krank wie vor schwere
vor all den besuch wo einbehalt verwandt
ist er sehr freuen
bester ist eine wirkliche schwester für
mich seit ich sie kenne sind wir
zusammen ein problem habe hilft er mir
umgekehrt mache ich für sie was ich kann
aber ich weiß dass sie viel mehr macht
als ich
wir denken und handeln ist vollkommen
geprägt durch die 68er bewegung
klassenkampf kommunismus freiheit viele
sieht sie heute anders aber von einer
besseren welt träumt sie noch immer
was muss krieche ich dass ich
grundsätzlich für andere geräte
materialistisch egoistische gesellschaft
wo wenig solidarität und das finde ich
da in burkina faso wo solidarität von
mensch zu mensch und wo der mensch im
mittelpunkt steht und nöte materielle
wachstum im mittelpunkt steht ihr großes
vorbild ist thomas ankara als linke
revolutionär kommen 1983 in burkina faso
durch einen staatsstreich an die macht
sang carrell interne rückzahlung der
schulden der dritten welt an den westen
ab
zudem begründete er eine ambitionierte
gesundheits und frauenpolitik 1987
putschte ihnen weggefährte aus dem amt
lanka wurde dabei getötet
die verehrerin der thomas st
den zieht anna maria maul binder werden
legitimieren waren über macht und und
kurz fit machen fürs volk
gold ist für mich nie legitimiert eine
geschichte also bald diese einfach
anderweitig und sie findet statt und
waren aus der cloud nach rap is gut sind
dort umso besser aber das legitimiert
war für mich eine bürgerwehr unterwegs
in burkina faso
so gewählt dass in dem westafrikanischen
land alltäglich geworden
terroranschläge und raubüberfälle haben
seit dem militärputsch vor vier jahren
zugenommen
die nachbarschaft patrouillen sind eine
reaktion auf die mangelnde präsenz der
polizei die gewalt hat auch ist der
kreis bekanntenkreis erreicht ihr
kollege nico basso ist noch immer
traumatisiert denn vor ein paar monaten
erschoss ein mann ein kind
daraufhin verfolgte ihn die bürgerwehr
der täter versteckte sich dann
ausgerechnet im haus von nebel fassung
ich habe mein velo hier abgestellt dann
ging ich zum eingang
als ich mein zuhause betrat hörte ich
ein geräusch jemand stand hinter der tür
als ich mich umdrehte attackierte mich
ein mann mit dem messer erstach hier
hinein was sowohl der schwer verletzt
er überlebte nur weil es dem die
operation bezahlt ist er bedeutet mir
alles
sie ist meine mutter sie ist meine
retterin ich musste man schon auftreten
der täter flüchtete und wurde noch im
dorf von der bürgerwehr gestellt nach
einer schießerei waren er und drei
weitere personen tot
trotz zunehmender gewalt in burkina faso
ist er frei lässt sich ihren idealismus
nicht nehmen
das sind wahrlich dort dass er wieder
weg die hofer toll dass mit der neuen
gesellschaft wo sich da auch angerichtet
dass das jetzt geburts mehr sind als er
sie lag mit dem risiko leben und sterben
das kürzungen und wollte zurück auf der
ganzen welt
da kann man versuchen sich gegenseitig
schweizer börse hat die hand sich
verteidigen kann man damit die menschen
hat man gleich an jener stelle begraben
wo sie umgebracht wurden
und jetzt müssen ein paar häuser wegen
des vorfalls abgerissen werden um den
nach altem brauch muss man den hof
verlassen wenn man darauf gewährt
geflossen ist
das gelände ist verflucht und bringt der
familie unglück was so kann heute wieder
als tanzlehrer arbeiten
[Musik]
einmal in der woche ist auch ist der
freie mit dabei afrikanischer tanz ist
schon seit 30 jahren ihr hobby
die gemeinschaft ist ihre familie
geworden
unabhängig zu bleiben ist ihr aber
ebenso wichtig deshalb ist das thema
partnerschaft für sie abgeschlossen
[Musik]
ihr zuhause ist von einer mauer umgeben
sie schützt aber nur bedingt vor
unerwünschten besuch muss alles
abschlüsse waren immer irgendwo meine
ruh muss gang mit dem schlüssel
abschließen
der bergsteiger insgesamt nur zweimal wo
es dann wirklich schwierig sich einmal
wo die computer wächst und einmal rot
karte weg sie ist in den zuschussbetrag
wo völlig verschmerzbar sind die
diebstähle beschäftigen sie dagegen will
sie etwas unternehmen etwas für europäer
eher außergewöhnliches
[Musik]
es geht nach st
das dorf liegt rund 25 km von esther
fries wohnort entfernt
im see am ortsrand von semmel des von
krokodilen
sie gelten als heilig eines der
reptilien soll nun der schweizerin
helfen sie vor diebstählen zu bewahren
und das geht so wird das huhn vom
krokodil gefressen geht der wunsch in
erfüllung so besagt es zumindest die
jahrhunderte auf die legende der frage
was jetzt vorhanden
die zahl der hier betrieben wurde mit
koloraturen vor allem ihr verwalteten
ihre politiker
das ritual hat dann sind die torlinie
überzeugt dass das funktioniert also als
ein wunsch in erfüllung geht wo sie
haben ja das ist total doof bank der
stadt hof statt sich durch es nie aber
ich glaube ich hoffe darauf und das
krokodil war so viel dusel vorjahres der
baltisch das weiß wirklich viel über
traut wie mir
[Musik]
yahoo
das lied ist ein alter afrikanischer
einen ruf und mit dem jenseits in
kontakt zu kommen
die renterin beschäftigt sich oft mit
dem älterwerden und der vergänglichkeit
allen lebens das ist der friedhof von
äußeren quartier zac efron ich hoffe
dass ich dort begraben wird
und sie sagt dann aus burkina bei school
at durchs wallis
das werde ich also sie waren dort kein
paul kruck kann man sie genau im alten
andere gesundheitlich nicht gutgeht sie
bittet in burkina faso sterbe ich denke
das ist für mich buch vor dem altersheim
das ist die us-werke nichts gefehlt da
bin ich besser ruft opitz um so lange
wie möglich gesund sie und dann
möglichst knie sterbe nicht sagen ob sie
brauchen plagte sind sie sicher dass für
sie gut wird
ich überlasse ich bin überzeugt ich habe
mich vorbereitet so liebevoll wenn ich
mit unseren umgang
da ist zum beispiel gerade etwas
variiert so einfaches grad und es dauert
nur rhythmus an und es ist so allgemein
es ist nett es individuum
es ist einfach eine mutter erklärt wird
und das ist es wohl nicht dass er stimmt
natürlich hof des der frei auf ein
langes leben
deshalb will sie sich auch gesund
ernähren so konnte sie eine
bauernfamilie überzeugen biogemüse und
zu bauen
verbrauch und wann das vorprojekt wenn
ich bin doch es ist gut die qualität es
sind sachen wo man weitere publikum
einfach auf dann suche ich vor allem im
restaurant wo abnehmer während das sie
nach als familienbetrieb über sachen
verkaufen
und was das war richtig läuft werden sie
darauf sicherlich waren dann wollte ich
dass die familie trafen
ist der freiheit träumt nicht nur von
einer besseren welt sie will sich eine
so er auch erschaffen
die arbeit werde wohl nie ausgehen
[Musik]